journée de commémoration aux états unis
ce 22 octobre est consacrée à la lutte
contre les violences policières pour la
26e édition des associations ont prévu
des rassemblements dans le pays au-delà
du mouvement de la classe amateur la
question des violences policières
continue d'alimenter l'actualité et les
débats politiques thomas gonnet
la question des violences policières est
un sujet récurrent est particulièrement
inflammable aux états unis au delà de la
très médiatisée affaire georges floyd il
y à une réalité qui est très
certainement sous-estimé
une récente étude affirme que les
statistiques officielles en matière de
morts engendrés par la police est très
nettement inférieur à la réalité selon
les données de cette étude entre 1980 et
2000 18 30 mille huit cents personnes
seraient mortes suite à des violences
policières alors que les statistiques
officielles elle ne relève qu'à peine la
moitié comme le montre notre analyse la
violence mortelle de la police et les
grandes disparités raciales dans cette
violence sont restées largement
inchangées ou ont augmenté depuis 1990
alors cette étude a des relents
politiques puisque ses auteurs se disent
par exemple favorable aux coupes
budgétaires engagées dans les services
de police de plusieurs grandes villes
américaines defence de police c'est
d'ailleurs un slogan récurrent au sein
du mouvement black like the matters
alors que pour d'autres justement ce
sont ces réductions budgétaires qui ont
conduit à une augmentation du nombre de
crimes aux états unis le sujet est donc
éminemment politique avec toujours cette
fracture entre démocrates et
républicains
et il faut d'ailleurs se souvenir du
clip de campagne publié l'an passé par
les équipes de joe biden et de camara
informe tous ici
mais les promesses du candidat byden se
sont heurtés à la réalité politique du
congrès américain faute d'accord le
projet de réforme de la police n'a pas
abouti démocrates et républicains se
rejetant la faute de manière regrettable
les sénateurs républicains ont rejeté
deux modestes réforme que même l'ancien
président avait soutenu tout en refusant
d'agir sur des points clés que même les
forces de l'ordre étaient prêtes à
discuter le crime va continuer
d'augmenter pendant que la sécurité
diminue et plus d'officiers de police
vont quitter leur poste parce que mes
partenaires de négociation ont quitté la
table plus d'un an après les larges
manifestations dans le cadre du
mouvement black live matters les
militants restent donc à pleinement
mobilisée pour tenter d'influencer la
politique menée par joe biden mais faute
de consensus le locataire de la maison
blanche a une marge de manoeuvre très
faible sur cette question avec le risque
de décevoir une partie de son électorat